AI 算出蛋白質會摺成什麼形狀
做出 AlphaFold 的人拿了諾貝爾化學獎
這段故事很多人講過
這次講的人，當年坐在評審席上
她叫 Chaok Seok
首爾大學化學系教授
做蛋白質結構預測做了 27 年
這集是韓國公共電視 EBS 的科學節目
為了今年的諾貝爾獎季做的
9 月 18 號播出
蛋白質是胺基酸串成的長鏈
會自己摺成立體的形狀
形狀決定它能做什麼
以前用實驗解一個形狀
博士生得花上 4、5 年
所以有人想直接用算的
難在一個蛋白質平均有 300 個胺基酸
每一個都有好幾種擺法
假設一個胺基酸可以有 10 種擺法
全部乘起來，乘 300 個
就是 10 乘 300 次，10 的 300 次方種可能
10 的 300 次方，很難吧
不是難，是不可能
不可能
光聽到 300 次方，壓力就好大
這要怎麼算啦
一種一種試不可能，只能靠預測
1994 年
做結構預測的人辦了一場全球比賽
叫 CASP，每 2 年一次
拿實驗剛解出來、還沒公開的結構出題
再用實驗的答案打分數
她的團隊常在這裡拿獎牌
在 CASP 比賽裡，教授您不只下場比
AlphaFold 參賽那幾年，您還當過評審
連評審都當了
因為我自己也是參賽者
所以我評的是我沒報名的其他組別
選手還被請去當評審
各位，這才是真正的蛋白質女王
2018 年，AlphaFold 第一版出來
2020 年，拿諾貝爾獎的第二版出來
那時評審團在瑞士開評分會議
在會議上一看，居然這麼強
之前的分數大概在這裡
那一次突然往上衝了一大截
AlphaFold 突然「砰」一聲，實力整個跳上去
那時候您是什麼心情？
這到底該說是人類輸了
還是該說「唉唷，你這小子幹得好」
我原本以為這輩子不可能看到的事
就這樣成真了，我真的很高興
做科學的人，不是為了自己要贏
而是在幾百年來科學家疊起來的東西上面
再多放一顆石頭
如果我們之中有誰，在一路累積下來的科學文明上
做出了什麼成就
身為跟他活在同一個時代的人
能親眼看到，也是很大的喜悅
您是開心地接受了
換成是我，應該會很火大
感覺被搶走了
像被搶走，又像被甩在後面
可是教授，您說 AlphaFold 一出來成績就突然超好
大家沒問嗎？這到底是怎麼做到的
比賽是這樣，那年夏天大家解題
12 月公布結果
那時候 AlphaFold 團隊上台報告
John Jumper 上台報告
執行長 Demis Hassabis 也報告了
可是在線上開，因為疫情
對
大家都很想知道，分數怎麼能這麼高
超想問的
結果他們隨便報告一下，真正想知道的都不講
而且又是線上
線上的問題多到爆
當然啊，大家都好奇
對啊，他們就說「我們用 AI 解的」
大家是想說，AI 我們知道啊，到底怎麼做的
那是 DeepMind 耶，當然是用 AI
只講最基本的，把報告時間撐滿
然後說「我們還在徵人」，就下線了
不過他們說之後會發論文
論文倒是寫得非常詳細
喔，有寫喔？那就原諒他們吧
那篇論文是不是拖很久？
對，拖了很久才出來
技術門檻嘛
大概是想多守一段時間，只有他們跨得過的門檻
可以這樣猜
論文您一定看過吧？內容怎麼樣？
祕訣是什麼？
祕訣嘛，既然是 AI，資料就很重要
解結構的研究做了很久很久
累積了大概 10 萬個結構的資料，這很重要
她說光有資料還不夠
AlphaFold 另外吃進了兩樣東西
一樣是物理，原子之間怎麼互相拉扯
這些規則被寫進了模型
另一樣是演化，同一種蛋白質
人跟鯨魚、馬身上都有，形狀差不多
胺基酸的順序卻各不相同
把這些親戚的序列擺在一起比
就找得到結構的線索
利用序列裡演化資訊的這個想法
90 年代就有了
哇
90 年代末就有了
那麼多科學家的研究跟論文
他們拼了老命做出來的資料
被 AI 插根吸管，一口氣全吸走了
您說吸管，其實說得沒錯
可是科學本來就是這樣進步的
一大堆科學家把東西全部上傳
它再全部吸過去，做出來的
科學家流血流汗解了幾十年的問題
AI 一出現，反正就是解掉了
那時候科學家的反應應該很兩極吧
那時候怎麼樣？
大家都嚇壞了
有些人想說，那我以後要做什麼
Jumper 跟 Hassabis 報告完
那時候大家以為
蛋白質結構的問題全都解完了
後來我去參加一場學術研討會
有位研究者就這樣說
「那我以後要做什麼」
講著講著就哽咽了
哇，真的假的？像迷路了一樣
主持人接著問
結構預測是不是就這樣解完了
她說解掉了很多，還沒解完的
是那些一直在晃動
沒有固定形狀的蛋白質
另外
地球上所有生物的蛋白質加起來超過 2 億種
實驗解出來的只有 25 萬個左右
您說地球上的蛋白質有 2 億種
AlphaFold 大概完美預測了多少個？
AlphaFold 只要有胺基酸序列
就能預測結構
所以幾乎所有已知的蛋白質
它都算出結構，放進資料庫了
接近 2 億個？
對對對
不過預測終究是預測
裡面有對的，也有錯的
我沒有數過
嗯，大概一半吧
一半？那就是 1 億個，也太驚人了
而且它會說「這個我有把握」
「這個我沒把握」
這種分數它也一起給，所以非常好用
沒把握的，它自己會打個三角形
會念書的學生都這樣，這題沒把握、這題有把握
對，就像那樣
那位哭出來的研究者，還在做研究嗎？
應該還在做，應該很認真在做
應該用得很順手吧
對，用得很好
而且 AlphaFold 如果說「這個結構我覺得是對的」
現在幾乎都可以說是準的
這種的，現在不做實驗也信得過
換個角度說，AlphaFold 預測得好的那些
就不用再做實驗了
然後是更有意思的，那些會晃動的蛋白質
去弄清楚它為什麼要這樣晃，才做得到這件事
這種研究好玩多了
所以現在非常多科學家都在用
一個研究生要流血流汗流淚 5 年的事
現在不用再做了
AI 出現了
您覺得之後的研究會怎麼變？
講到蛋白質設計這個領域
把現有的改得更好，叫做最佳化
以前也常叫它工程改造
現在連從頭做出全新的都辦得到了
創造出本來沒有的東西
這叫 de novo 設計
用 de novo 做
從零做出來
連這個都做得到了
這幾乎是神的領域
其實我本來也覺得那是神的領域
AlphaFold 出來之前，我沒想過做得到
哇
從零設計，就是先想好要它做什麼
再回頭設計一個自然界沒有的蛋白質去做
她說最有用的地方是新藥
很多難治的病
關鍵在某一個蛋白質出了問題
設計一個專門去卡住它的分子
就有機會治
她的實驗室也自己開發設計用的 AI
我們到現在設計過的蛋白質非常多
針對大概 20、30 個目標
我們在設計完全沒出現過的新蛋白質
研究做成了，就直達諾貝爾獎了吧
有可能啊，做到以前做不到的事的話
有機會吧，我們 Seok 教授，對吧？
你們一直把話題往那邊帶
當然要去啊
我們這邊已經有好幾位預約了
這個只要做成，諾貝爾獎就穩了
不過這一塊競爭應該很激烈吧？
對，競爭非常激烈
拿了諾貝爾獎的 Google，做完 AlphaFold
接著開了 Isomorphic Labs
一家做新藥的公司
Anthropic 也把一位諾貝爾得主挖過去
好像也要做新藥
還買下了一家藥廠
她說的那位諾貝爾得主
節目畫面上打出來的新聞寫的是 John Jumper
也就是 2020 年在線上報告 AlphaFold 的那個人
4 年後
他跟 Hassabis 一起拿了諾貝爾化學獎
所以教授您等於在跟他們競爭
教授，這次拜託了
教授一講到自己的成就就很害羞
您的研究團隊，在全世界
老實說排第幾？
您覺得大概第幾名？老實講
不久前我還覺得是第一名
很確定的第一名
那現在呢
現在是不安的
不安的第一名吧，或是前幾名之一
那蛋白質設計什麼時候能真的拿來用
用在治病上呢？教授
現在已經在靠近了
Demis Hassabis 跟其他 AI 領袖
有人說 10 年、15 年內，幾乎所有疾病都能克服
有人這樣講過
那只要再健康活個 15 年
撐一下就好
MC，到時候你真的可以長生不老
真的好想喔
身為一個把一輩子都給了蛋白質研究的科學家
想問 Seok 教授，您最終的目標是什麼
最終目標
如果說我一直朝著哪個方向在跑
那就是理解生命
理解有生命存在的這個世界
再用這些理解
去創造出我們需要的東西
往這個方向走，就是我在追求的
AlphaFold 解掉了她花大半輩子在做的題目
她的第一個反應是高興
現在她用 AI 做世界上沒有的蛋白質
同一條路上多了 Google 和 Anthropic
這個第一名，她坐得不太安穩
原影片 39 分鐘
前半段她從頭講蛋白質
也講到疫情那年
她的團隊把別人解出來的新冠棘蛋白片段拼起來
補上缺的根部，做出完整的立體結構
同桌做天文的來賓也說
一張星空照片裡有幾千萬個天體
不靠 AI 根本分不完
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。